they have appeared on state TV and I've
seen the video both men look okay Aiden
Aslan has a cut down the middle of his
forehead
um they look pretty tired they look
pretty exhausted they say they're okay
they say they're being fed and watered
but it would appear as though certainly
in terms of Aiden he's being encouraged
to say certain things to camera because
there is an unidentified man who's
asking him questions really about
um what appears to be the azov Battalion
the Nationalist Battalion in mariupole
and he is being asked pretty leading
questions
um for example uh
you know he's asked in Russian why those
people killed civilians and Aiden
replies because they're criminals he's
asked again weren't you surprised by
this attitudes towards civilians
and he talks about the fact that they
were looting supermarkets where people
who didn't have food should have been
getting food so certainly leading
questions I think which were meant to be
shown on Russian State TV to blacken the
name of those Ukrainian fighters who
Russia characterizes as all nationalists
and how they were not looking after the
remaining civilians in mariopol I think
that is the strategy now what um these
two men were asking for is to be
exchanged for Victor medvedic who is
this pro-russian Ukrainian politician
who two days after this special military
operation as Russia insists on calling
it began was
escaped from his house arrest and was
only recently last week recaptured by
Ukrainian authorities Victor medvedic is
a very interesting individual I
interviewed him actually back in 2019
around the elections then When Vladimir
zielinski came to power he's believed to
be the Godfather of Vladimir Putin
daughter he led a pro-russian faction
within the parliament an extremely
wealthy man he ran pro-russian
television channels and had pretty much
a media Empire and then he was accused
last year by zelenski of treason and put
under house arrest and that was thought
to be perhaps one of the reasons why
um Vladimir Putin felt uh that that
really alongside zelenski are asking
pushing to join NATO that he was making
anti-russian moves that Russia could
know no longer tolerate that is at least
one of many many theories that have been
put forward as to why uh Vladimir Putin
decided to choose now to go into Ukraine
um simultaneously with this video being
released on uh State tv of the two
britons we've had a video released by
Victor by the Ukrainian Special Forces
sbu of victim Advent took asking the
Russian president to be released in
exchange for Ukrainian forces still in
mariopol and any citizens who are still
unable to access humanitarian corridors
and leave the city so there do seem to
be a lot of requests being made to Boris
Johnson to Vladimir Putin to exchange
various people around Victor Medved
Chuck and these two Brits and we do
believe there is another Britain also
who's been fighting
um with the Ukrainian forces in Mario
poll who may have been captured we don't
know where these men are whether they're
in Russia itself or still in uh in and
around mariu poll we have yet to hear of
course from the Prime Minister but we
have heard from the Kremlin who said
last week that um Victor vegic was a
Ukrainian citizen he is not a Russian
national he doesn't have anything to do
with the special military operation and
there therefore they can't consider a
prisoner swap in exchange for Ukrainian
forces but it does depend really on
Vladimir Putin given the kind of close
allegiance that he does have with the
Russian president so we'll have to see
how this goes but certainly the fact
that these two men have been broadcast
on state TV is a way I think of trying
to communicate that the bad guys in this
or the nationalists battalions in
mariupole who have been essentially
holding civilians there hostage that is
the fundamental narrative on state TV
about why marayupo is the child remains
of a city that it is because they say
nationalist battalions neo-nazis as they
like to call them all over State tv are
holding civilians essentially as human
Shields which means that the Russians
need to Target these civilian
infrastructure to get rid of the
militants
um so we'll have to see what happens
with the fate of these two men but they
did say that they were okay and they did
look
um
pretty much okay no visible signs of of
abuse